[Musik] [Applaus]
[Musik]
servus Berlin ich bin plus Kummer weil das halt in
der Brauerei stattfindet hat man was erhofft mir
hat keiner was von Kultur gesagt in meinem Beruf
hat es den Vorteil dass man immer weiter lernen
darf also man lernt nie aus als Kabarettistin
das liegt auch daran weil mir nach den Auftritten
immer viele nette Menschen nur Dinge erklären
die vielleicht einfach nicht weiß oder nicht
verstanden habe Männer zu voll denke ich aber ich
bin eigentlich auch froh drüber weil wie hätte ich
als Frau ansonsten Zugang zur Bildung ich bin
halt darauf angewiesen dass mir da nette Männer
Dinge erklären und deswegen nehme ich das einmal
dankend an und dann ist neulich im Pfaffenhofen in
Bayern am Mann zu mir herkommen und hat sie
mir gesagt das war so Silberrücken Gorilla
wissen Sie eigentlich dass wenn sie über
ihre Tochter sprechen dass sie dann immer
das Possessivpronomen benutzen meine
Tochter aber dass man auch inzwischen
so davon weggekommen dass man den Kindern
so die eigene Persönlichkeit raubt doch
Possessivpronomen man verwendet
doch jetzt viel eher den Namen
ja dann habe ich mir das wahrscheinlich auch
bloß eingebildet dass sie die 42 Wochen lang
ausgetragen habe und davon 22 Wochen lang
liegen musste weil es in der 20 Woche wegen
der Unterleibsentzündung fast verloren hat
und ab dem Moment früh wählen gehabt habe und
wahrscheinlich aber mal Ablass eingebildet das
in der Zeit wo ich die früh wählen gehabt habe
ungefähr 4793 Leute mein Unterleib reingeschaut
haben und wenn es passiert hat dann mal kurz Nike
langt weil du dich da gar nicht wehren kannst
als Frauen früh wählen und weil Regensburg wo
ich herkommen gar nicht so große Stadt ist
wie Berlin waren da oft Menschen dabei die
mein Unterleib reingeschaut haben die habe
ich schon am Schulhof nicht leiden können
und bei Regensburg gar nicht so große Stadt
ist waren da Leute dabei da wollte wirklich
einmal dass sie meinen Unterleib reinschauen
wie der eine Typ in die Jahre lang verliebt war
aber halt nicht in der Notaufnahme in
sanktätigung um drei in der Früh und der
Regensburger Studentenstadt ist Warendorf 13
köpfige Studentengruppen von meinem Unterleib
gestanden im Bett und Kugelschreibern haben
Sie Notizen zu meinen frühen gemacht und ich
werde nie den einen Studenten vergessen der
sich gemeldet hat und gefragt hat und meine
Familie vielleicht an meinem Unterricht liegen
könnten oder an meinem fortgeschrittenen Alter
nach zwei Kindern mit frühwinen
noch zwei Schwangerschaften mir
früh gehen kann ich zweifelsohne sagen
halb Regensburg kennt meinen Unterleib
ich muss kaum Hosen mehr
anziehen wenn ich zum Aldi gehe
vollkommen unnötig bei mir passiert
manchmal dass sie im Freibad stehe am
Beckenrand und dann taucht jemand neben mir auf
und sagt haben wir doch doch dass du das bist
in mein sicher das liegt da meiner etwas
feierfreudigen Studentenzeit logisch aber
nicht nur wenn es in Regensburg mal wieder wetten
das gibt dann kannst du aus meinem Unterleib
letzten Endes machen so bekannteste aber das habe
mir sicher alles eine eingebildet genauso wie
die 29 Stunden Wehen in denen ich klingen bin bei
meiner Tochter wo die Herztöne gegangen sind dass
man die Hebamme auf dem Bauch aufgesprungen ist
und genauso wie das meine Tochter die Nabelschnur
zweimal und mein kopfwickel gehabt hat wie sie das
Licht der Welt der Blick hat und ich eigentlich
Glück gehabt habe dass ich überhaupt Heirat
braucht habe und ich habe mal wahrscheinlich
auch das eingebildet dass meine Tochter in dem
Moment zum Schreien angefangen hat als er aus dem
Bauch rausgekommen ist und aufgehört hat sie erst
vier Monate später weil sie war Überraschungen
und der bayerische Staat hat sich gedacht oh ja
junge Familie die trennen jetzt einfach da schickt
mir in Europa Bayern und sie darf in der Oberpfalz
bleiben für euch in Berlin ist es ungefähr so wie
wenn er einen Mitte ist unter anderem Neukölln
und dabei die ganze Zeit allein mit dem Kind und
das Kind hat die ganze Zeit geschrieben und wir
wissen ja wie das ist ne mit so einem Baby schlafe
wenn das Kind schläft mache die Wäsche wenn das
Kind die Wäsche macht und deswegen weil die ganze
Zeit fertig ich war die ganze Zeit ohne Schlaf und
dann habe ich um drei in der Nacht durch das Kind
einfach in die Wiege gelegt und habe Kopf das ist
nicht schüttelt und bin jetzt Nebenzimmer gegangen
und habe weint und wir haben dann geholfen meine
Mama und die hätte ich nicht geschafft aber das
hat man wahrscheinlich alles nein gebildet
genauso wie dass sie kritisiert worden bin
weil sie zu langstellung kritisiert worden
bin weil ich zu kurz still ich bin kritisiert
haben wie wieder in arbeitsdrucker bin und bin
kritisiert waren weil überhaupt daheim bin weil
es Frauen in dieser Gesellschaft nur falsch
machen kannst egal ob du erkennst oder nicht
[Musik]
und da will mein Kind der Pflegekind
Adoptivkind oder bonuskind wäre dann
würde mir das wahrscheinlich auch bloß einbilden
dass ihm die mal apropos sagt weil ich immer
apropos sage und dass die Sissi alle drei Teile
auswendig mitsprechen kann weil ich hier das
beigebracht habe und sie sehr früh gefördert
habe in dem Bereich weil ich da der Meinung
bin das ist Qualifikation dir wirklich immer
was bringt am Weihnachten beim Trinkspiel ne
und wie ist das Ullmann der Musiker in einem
Lied gesagt hat ich würde meine Tochter später
von jeder Arbeit abholen ich würde sie von ihrer
Zeit in Stammheim genauso abholen wie von ihrer
Zeit im Bundeskanzleramt ich werde die Mama die
am Parkplatz steht und sagt Mädel schickte ich
habe Scheiße einpackte hinter mir schaut schon
so grantig ne deswegen ich und in unserem Fall
wäre es aber wesentlich realistischer dass ich
sie mal von der Großraum Disco in karmaol und
Bayerischen Wald arbeitet aber da wird es
abholen übrigens auf Crystal Meth Fritzen
beim Abholen aber ich würde es holen weil
es meine Tochter in ihrem Leben gar nicht
so verscheißen könnte dass ich nicht für Sie da
wäre ich nicht alles für sich machen wird weil
ich sie auf diese Welt gebracht habe ohne Not und
weil ich ihre Mama bin und sie ist meine Tochter
der Mann hat dann gesagt der Rest von meinem
Programm war ganz okay streckenweise was
immer ein bisschen zu feministisch da
fehlt ihm dann etwas die Leichtigkeit
war dann sprachlos bin heimgefahren habe es
am nächsten Tag in der Früh beim Kaffee meiner
Tochter erzählt die sind zwischen 9 und dann hat
sie gesagt Mama wie oft soll er das jetzt nur
sagen mit besoffenen Leuten brauchst du überhaupt
nicht reden und übrigens eine Taxi fahrente servus
hallo na hier ist eine endcard das kennt
ja oder also was soll das immer das ist
sicher doch das wäre gut wenn er damals
das ist super witzig wahrscheinlich das
Video und das ist auch super witzig das
guckt ja immer besser beides dann und
hier abonnieren so und dann habt ihr auch
schon auch mal was zurückgegeben danke